The United States supports Israel.
Turkey supports the Palestine.
France supports the Israel.
Australia supports the Israel.
Iran supports the Palestine.
Norway supports the Israeli.
Canada supports the Israel.
Qatar supports the Palestine.
Syria supports the Palestine.
United Kingdom supports the Israel.
Saudi Arabia supports the Palestine.
Poland supports the Israel.
Germany supports the Israel.
Kuwait supports the Palestine.
Pakistan supports the Palestine.
India supports the Israel.
Lebanon supports the Palestine.
Bangladesh supports the Palestine.
New Zealand supports the Israel.
North Korea supports the Palestine.
Spain supports the Israel.
Algeria supports the Palestine.
Ukraine supports the Israel.
Malaysia supports the Palestine.
Iraq supports the Palestine.
Jordan supports the Palestine.
Arab League supports the Palestine.
European Union supports the Israel.